rod i want to get to turn the page
tuesday now it's these teams that have
maybe had a bad week one maybe a bad
week one and two that just have to flip
that page gonna start with a quarterback
who had a a bad draw it's a bad draw for
a rookie quarterback having to go play
bill belichick the ghost that he is able
to create for these rookie quarterbacks
rookie quarterbacks we've seen before as
well and zach wilson how does belichick
do this how does he create those ghosts
in their minds
first i got to say man zach you get a
pass all right you're going against a
great one and bill belichick is great at
going at rookie quarterbacks we get it
like we talked about on sunday a lot of
disguise a lot of man-to-man coverage a
lot of movement by the safeties and the
linebackers and the corners just never
giving him an opportunity to get to the
line of scrimmage and get comfortable
you know when he comes to the line of
scrimmage you don't know when you see
safeties and linebackers moving around
if it's going to be man coverage if it's
going to be zoned if it's going to be
pressure you just don't know and the
patriots do a great job of it but the
one thing that i did see and you see
this very often these rookies they're
top picks for a reason because they're
extremely confident and they bring that
same confidence with them playing
against
you know um other teams in the national
football league however this this ain't
college and the speed is totally
different and you saw zach wilson
dropping back trying to make plays that
you you can make in college but you
can't make in a national football league
these are the best defenders
in on the planet and you think you can
between three defenders of the the new
england patriots it's not going to
happen and you see him instead of just
throwing the ball away he tries to fit
it in there between another two people
him dropping back pressure in his face
and he just lets it go and it's just
another easy pick time and time again he
has to get back to doing the simple
things and then the jets have to do a
better job of allowing him to run the
football
and to to check it down
everything can't be deep and if you saw
a lot of those interceptions they were
down the field throws
i mean he looked dazed and confused
right there i mean dazed and confused
those are some of the ugliest
interceptions that you'll see in an nfl
game i mean he's throwing it
four separate occasions directly to a
new england patriot i mean ugly ugly
interceptions so i want to ask you this
like you mentioned to me on sunday you
used to do this to tom brady as well
these same things that they're doing to
zach wilson what do you think wilson's
seeing as he's walking up to the you
know you see stepping up there and the
shotgun maybe he's under center as he's
looking at the patriots defense what
specifically are you guys trying to make
him think it's cover two it's really
covered three like what specifically is
he seeing and why does he look like he's
never played quarterback before
you know what i don't know specifically
what he's watching because a lot of
quarterbacks are different some
quarterbacks like tom what tom does is
he walks right up to the line of
scrimmage and he looks at the middle
linebacker the mike linebacker and he
looks at the two safeties then once he
looks at the two safeties now tom is
scanning the field he's watching
everything he's watching how deep you
are he's watching your feet he's
watching how anxious you are he's
looking at the forums or the defensive
lineman seeing if you're going to drop
if you're going to rush tom sees
freaking everything and that's what he's
watching and a lot of rookie
quarterbacks they're coming to the line
of scrimmage they're saying okay i don't
know what coverage they're in they're
nervous i'm just gonna try to really
focus on my reads and just look at my
number one if he's not there then i'll
go to my number two but a lot of times
about time that happens now the rush is
in your face you're throwing it up and
now it's getting picked off so these
young guys they can't process
information like a veteran like tom
brady aaron rodgers the patrick mahomes
and things like that because they just
haven't seen enough of these defenses
yet
i could listen to you talk defensive
football all day man that's that's so
awesome it's like just the way that you
can describe the disguising and all that
stuff you know you you you'd be a hell
of a defensive coordinator so much fun
told you that before
it's so awesome to listen you talk okay
let's get to borough right joe burroughs
another quarterback ready to turn the
page a little bit with the bengals
struggles interceptions if you watch the
fourth quarter i mean it just fell
completely off the rails for the bengals
for borough where did all of this come
from how much of it's on joe the
offensive line what were the bengals
struggles on sunday
well i mean i just think that you know
we talked about it and we said we saw
the bengals and we saw the offensive
line firing on and things like that but
a lot of times when you have success
early and you have um
you have who is the kid the chase what's
his name
jamar chase i'm the rookie receiver
you're talking about jamar chase yeah
yeah yeah you have jamar chase you have
tyler boyd you have all these weapons
now the offensive coordinator he thinks
you could just drop back and just sling
the ball around but you also have joe
mixon joe mixon is a quality back okay a
lot of people don't talk about joe mixon
because he plays for the bengals they
don't give him respect but if you know
football and you watch football joe
mixon is that dude he's a stud they have
to feed him more you can't just drop
back because you have a talented young
quarterback because you know the
defenses and these defensive
coordinators getting two three million
bucks to design defenses to frustrate
and to confuse those rookie quarterbacks
so to me
i would say to most of these head
coaches these offensive coordinators
back down a little bit run the football
give them some quick hidden things that
allow him to get his confidence back and
not everything has to be down the field
so i saw a couple of things in this
bengals game and i i'm from cincinnati i
live in cincinnati bengals have brought
my heart out stomped on the ground
multiple times listen man i grew up in
bangladesh right i'm just going to call
it what it is and here's what i saw
yesterday i a lot of it was not on
burrow the offensive line was struggling
the bears were doing a whole bunch of
these sweeping slants with their
defensive line and the bengals have kind
of patched together and put band-aids on
this offensive line and they were
tricking them with them and burrow's
getting hit in the ear when he thinks he
still had time on multiple occasions the
other thing i saw was these young wide
receivers are going to be awesome and at
moments they are awesome jamar chase was
really screwing them on multiple
occasions in this game they brought him
in one time on a third and short to
block eddie jackson he let eddie jackson
run right by him blow up the play in the
backfield there's another occasion
they're going to throw a screen out
there to jamar chase everything's set up
all the linemen are going over there is
wide open borough looks at him he's
looking to drop it off to him and jamar
chase is running down the field with no
clue what he's doing and then burro is
getting drilled by khalil mack so these
young wide receivers made a bunch of
mistakes if you go look at even t
higgins dropping the football he had the
one he catches it across the middle and
just fumbles it um even even um 83 what
the heck is his name tyler boyd he had
ran a couple of routes
drifting back
and it winds up being an interception so
i thought the young receivers on the
road for the bengals really struggled in
this game as with the offensive line and
it put burrow in some really bad spots
so it takes the head coach zach taylor
to reel everything in and it just shows
his inexperience too as the head guy not
kind of just
dialing these guys back you know if you
know your quarterback is struggling and
you know these young wide receivers are
struggling like i talked about before
run the football now you can probably
use play action pass the bears are tough
man they got they got an outstanding
front they got you know they got some
really great linebackers secondary is
kind of shaky right now but
it's it's just one of those things
that's going to take time but i still
like what cincinnati's doing i like the
energy that they play with they they
have some a lot of young talent and i
think they're going to be pretty good
and that kid baits on the defensive side
jesse bates he is a stud if they don't
pay him they need to pay that man i know
cincinnati they have a history and you
know this more than me of not wanting to
pay somebody pay that guy jesse bates is
a stud at safety
they don't love paying people here in
cincinnati but he does deserve it he
does deserve it the other thing that
bengals we're dealing with is that the
bears just got whooped by the rams
they're coming home for their home
opener after getting whooped in week one
and that usually is a recipe knowing
that that team is going to come in
looking for a fight and the bears were
looking for a fight bengals are riding
high after a week one win and then boom
all that stuff happens let's get to the
rams though kenny young of the rams he
had a job to do he made did his job this
week what did you see from kenny young
making some mistakes out there with
outlet
i just saw a frustration with kenny
young i mean you're right now you have a
goal line stand you're stopping the
coach one of the best offensive lines in
all of football and you can't get up and
get frustrated and yell and scream and
bump an official you can't do that it
hurts the team it hurts you you're a
starter you're a guy that they depend on
and i understand you're frustrated but
at the end of the day look at them look
at number 79 they're all celebrating
they're saying you're a starter get the
heck out of here aaron donald even tries
to pull him to the side and talk to him
like aaron donald's the best player on
the planet and he's telling you god keep
your composure we don't need that
kenny young made it all about himself
and you as a defender as a guy in that
situation a leader on that team you
can't do that you have to keep keep your
composure and you can't cost your team
how do you sort of channel because you
got to be a little crazy to go play
football and play goal line football and
you got to be playing a little angry a
little mad having that attitude about
you how do you have that edge and also
have the composure was that something
you had to learn over your career too
like how do you find that balance and
then how do you lead guys and make sure
they find the balance too
it's called being a professional that's
what it's called when you're a pro and
you're a grown man you know what to do
because he's getting paid millions of
dollars to play linebacker in the
national football league make tackles
and you know the difference between
right and wrong when you bump an
official they tell you that even when
you're in peewee you can't touch an
official so you're getting an official's
face and he's just an innocent bystander
sitting there you may not like the call
whether you like it or not that's that
doesn't that doesn't even matter the
fact is that you disrespected the
official you're yelling cussing
screaming in his face and you you
actually bump him that's what hurts the
team so you just have to be a pro and
understand that yeah you're a big part
of the team but it's not about you and
when it's not about you you just play
your role and do your job and when you
do that you're fine but when you don't
do that then you get kicked out of the
game and you hurt your team
yeah it's true they're lucky that this
didn't cost them the game really if you
think about it think about the whole
scope of that game they're lucky to be
able to fight back and figure out a way
to win this thing and the nfl in general
they're just not going to allow any of
this anymore i think i think more than
anything what they're trying to do is
project
a perfect brand of football if you will
onto the younger generations they don't
want the taunting anymore they don't
want any conversations after the whistle
i personally disagree a little bit i
mean there's some things the kenny young
thing too far i got that but there's
some moments you know where guys are
just it's so aggressive and such a
fast-paced crazy game that if they have
a little words with each other like
right after a whistle as long as it
stays within the lines i have no problem
with that i think some of these taunting
calls are going way off the rails kenny
young's a different scenario i got that
but what are your thoughts on these
taunting calls we saw a lot of them
through the first couple of weeks here
you just don't know you you don't know
what you're hearing like we're watching
the game whether we're there or whether
we're watching on television like you
don't know what they're saying because
they could be like
mf and yelling and screaming and cussing
and you don't know i mean like they're
showing emotion and they're kind of
demonstrative but you don't know the
words that are coming out of their mouth
and the officials hear that if you're
dropping cuss words and stuff like that
they're going to throw a flag at you and
if you happen to
just brush and officials do let me tell
you something i played 15 years and i
was involved in a lot of skirmishes okay
and officials have always done a really
good job of kind of letting it play out
not penalizing people because they have
a feel those guys know these guys are
getting paid a lot of money it's a lot
of pressure on them so the officials do
a really good job but in that case with
kenny young you could just tell with all
the emotion that he was showing that it
wasn't like it was um hallmark cards
coming out of his mouth he was going off
and when you touch the official that's a
no-no he deserves to get kicked out of
the game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports